If you have trouble picturing this think about a mountain climber. It would be
harder for a mountain climber to walk from left to right across this graph than
it would for someone to walk from left to right on this graph but we're
mathematicians and it's not enough to know that this line is steeper than this
line. I want to know how much steeper, I need a way of quantifying steepness In
algebra we use something called slope. Slope compares the distant a line rises
or falls to the distance aligned runs from left to right. We write slope as the
ratio of rise divided by run. For example, let's look at this line. We'll look
at the graph between x equals 0 and x equals 1, so we're between here. In this
region we have a run of 1 so I'll put 1 in the denominator. How much would this
rise be? Use the graph to help you out.